haben sie sich manchmal damals auch so
ein bisschen gefühl zurück und droht als
würde man sie mundtot machen wollen es
wenn sie so eine nebenrolle irgendwie
albums gab beim und wird auf jeden fall
nicht und so gesehen ist es ja irgendwie
auch die nebenrolle man weil man in dem
fall also der job das amt ist das amt
des bundespräsidenten hoffentlich bald
auch einer bundespräsidentenwahl
und dann gibt es in partner partnerin
dem fall waren es bisher halt immer
partnerinnen ehefrauen und da ist man
natürlich dann frau von so hat natürlich
ab trotzdem ja einen eigenen bereich
einen eigenen terminkalender kann es
unglaublich viel bewegen kann themen
nach vorne pushen und auch setzen
aber letztlich ist auch ganz klar
zurückhaltung geboten also gerade
natürlich selber sieht das ist schwer
weil sie sind so eine starke frau dass
sie nicht mal zwischen dieser tage jetzt
reicht's aber macht das doch mal bitte
so und so das kann man ja sagen das kann
man ja im hintergrund auch sagen dass er
hinter verschlossenen türen werden ja
auch wird ja auch diskutiert und
gesprochen und das ist sicherlich auch
bei jedem bundespräsidenten der fall mit
frau aber letztlich nach außen ist es
ganz klar deklariert der bundespräsident
die bundespräsidentin wird im amt
gewählt und nicht die ehefrau ergebnis
gibt es etwas was sie vorher nicht
wussten was ihnen dann so schwer
gefallen ist während des amtes weil
patrick hat gesagt hat mehr gehen hätte
es ja wissen müssen aber was gibt s was
wir nicht wissen wir ja in diesen
strukturen ist was man eigentlich als
selbstbestimmte frau kaum aushält
möglicherweise also was man kaum aushält
kann man jetzt nicht sagen man muss das
auch mal ganz klar sehen wie sie auch
schon im winter natürlich ist es einfach
auch eine unglaubliches privileg
es ist ein großes privileg dort sein zu
dürfen
die bundesrepublik deutschland
präsentieren repräsentieren zu dürfen
das heißt auch dass man sich an
bestimmte auch protokollarische regeln
hält und halten muss weil es das auch
einfacher macht das ist und auch einfach
klare spielregeln wenn verschiedene
kulturen aufeinandertreffen das bis
dahin planen gibt es das da irgendwie
sich alle mit wohlfühlen darum geht es
natürlich auch aber innerhalb dieses
protokolls dieses rahmens ist es
manchmal schon wäre hätte ich mir schon
gewünscht dass es manchmal auch
vielleicht ein bisschen menschlicher
zugegangen wäre ja und wie sehr schlimm
sind wie man sich wirklich
man bekommt eine ahnung natürlich
dadurch wir sage ich jetzt mal nix und
ich wir waren ja auch nicht wir sind da
ja nicht einfach hinein geworfen worden
mein ex mann war vorher jahrelang
ministerpräsident eines bundeslandes da
kann man auch schon ordentlich üben
sozusagen
aber wie ist dann wirklich ist wenn man
dann da tatsächlich ja im amt steht das
ist tatsächlich etwas ist kann man
vorher also ich hab mir nicht vorstellen
ich konnte dann doch nicht letztlich ein
schützen was waren das die schwersten
momente die man da so hat also ich
stelle mir first lady und trotzdem aber
zweite geige
das ist jetzt eigentlich nichts was alle
mir zuerst mal jugendliche in ordnung
war als zweite geiger habe ich auch nie
so betrachtet denn wie gesagt man hat
als frau dann in dem fall des
bundespräsidenten auch einen ganz
eigenen bereich man hat man kann also
man hat erstmals schirmherrschaften
dastehen steht das steht einem frei ob
man die übernimmt oder nicht man kann
auch sagen worauf als sie nicht genau wo
sie noch mal überlegen
und man kann selber themen auch setzen
platzieren und mitbringen so zu sagen
und dann hat man da eine ziemlich große
spielwiese fasst sich auch wirklich
dinge zu bewegen menschen einzuladen
so auch sozusagen sichtbar zu machen was
in deutschland alles getan wird wie für
ehrenamtliche tätigkeiten viele
ehrenamtliche power ist in deutschland
gibt das ist eigentlich so die die
themen die man als frau des
bundespräsidenten wirklich nach vorne
nach vorne zeigen kann
auf der anderen seite ist es ja auch
nicht wirklich ein politisches amt aber
ganz ganz gut
sie haben eben gerade nämlich sagt bevor
wir davon ganz bekommen es wäre schön
ist eine bundespräsident hingeht wenn ja
warum und wer käme dafür in frage wer
sowas wäre wer wäre
der wunschkandidat ihm dafür den wenn
sie also da würde ich würde ich da würde
ich mich komplett aus halten natürlich
dafür nicht umsonst kann das wäre
natürlich ist einfach das wäre ein
starkes zeichen und ich glaube das wäre
das wäre das stünde unserem land auch
gut zu bis ich glaube dass wir jetzt zu
sagen haben der kanzlerin ja dann auch
die zeit natürlich reif ist irgendwie
und eu-kommissarin präsidentin und und
also wirklich starken frauen die er
schon vorne sind
das ist zum beispiel könnt ihr jetzt
doch auch noch x mal schauen das
sicherlich geeignete kandidatinnen
sozusagen für die erste
bundespräsidentin
da müssen sie uns ihre geschichte also
quoten er für quotenfrauen landwirte
gehalt ich nichts aber genauso wie es
hieß großer die kandidaten gäbe gibt
sicherlich auch frauen die das super
machen so wie sie sind gegen die frau
wurde also per se für eine frauenquote
bin ich nicht aus krieg und und versucht
mich nämlich sehr interessieren bei
mistral kein name einfach wenn du dich
gerne mit mir sind märkten schönste von
der leyen hätte auch eine gute
wunderland den morden können diesen
schaden war im gespräch
margot käßmann war mal im gespräch ich
finde das schade wenn dir keine frau ein
feld also es gibt genug ich hab doch ein
paar grad ja ja genug tolle frauen in
unserem land aber wohl keinen namen
tatsächlich aber ich glaube es muss ja
auch nicht unbedingt jemand sein der
sowieso schon im politischen betrieb so
unheimlich verwoben und drin ist es
könnte ja auch mal jemand sozusagen
außerdem fachfremde seien aus einem ganz
anderen mit einem ganz anderen
hintergrund
das stünde vielleicht einfach der der
ganzen ja und dieser position und diesen
ganzen betrieb war ganz gut ich habe
noch eine frage wann ich das wirklich
interessiert sie sind jemand der
wirklich eine tolle ausstrahlung hat
wenn sie einen raum rein kommen und ich
finde nicht dass sozusagen zweite geige
oder so das passt er überhaupt nicht
wenn sie manchmal das gefühl dass sie
sozusagen auch mit ihrem auftreten in
ihrem wesen das was sie aus man auch das
protokoll konfrontiert habe in einer art
und weise das ist herausforderung
dargestellt
ich glaube es hat eher was damit zu tun
mit der ganz neuen situation auf beiden
seiten also ich sage mal bisher waren da
eben eher ältere herrschaften im haus
gewesen so zu sagen da war es waren
ältere bundespräsidenten ohne you kleine
kinder die ja noch irgendwie mit mit mit
dabei waren das keine patchworkfamilie
und die konstellation war einfach neu
und für uns ja auch und da gab es
einfach klar gab es erstmal muss erst
gab es ein annäherungsprozess und das
war selbstredend am anfang einfach
vieles anders als bei den vorgängerinnen
vorgängern in dem fall aber letztlich wo
wir sagen das war ja nicht das war kein
wirkliches problem das gibt's überall
wenn sie neuen job beginnen antreten
egal ob das in der wirtschaft ist sonst
wo
dann müssen sie sich ja erst einmal
akklimatisieren dann lernt sie die neuen
kolleginnen und kollegen kennen und dann
irgendwann der ziel so vielleicht auch
mal ein bisschen wie es bei ihnen zu
hause so ist und dann ja dann dann beim
wechsel passt
ich wollte eigentlich heute ein wilder
ein bisschen sollten wie sie schreiben
ja auch in ihrem buch so ich war oft im
innersten nicht zufrieden mit mir oder
zum beispiel auch darüber geschrieben
wie sehr sie sich dem protokoll auch
anpassen mussten ich meine emotionen
jegliche gefühlsregung mehr öffentlichen
auftritten muss sich unterdrücken was
ich wirklich dachte das muss ich für
mich war ja es ist doch irre druck der
jalil damit muss man leben sondern das
ist doch weniger druck kann aber man ist
auf der einen seite natürlich im druck
ausgesetzt weil
die öffentlichkeit eben da ist man ist
sehr präsent
auf der anderen seite dieses ich konnte
durfte nicht zeigen reflektiert er etwas
von mir selber ich hatte selber einen
anderen anspruch daran ich habe selber
gedacht ich muss so und so sein ich muss
ich muss natürlich da ein starkes
perfektes bild abgeben
von einer souverän frau die die so die
situation im griff hat aber das war mit
36 37 jahren in dem fall war das ja
nicht immer wirklich der fall also
natürlich war ich in den vielen momenten
auch einfach von diesem ganzen drumherum
wie jeder andere mensch das auch gewesen
wäre
auch einfach überfordert oder im
positiven sinne auch ein geplättet
also es sind einfach momente wo man
selber im nachhinein edward da war ich
jetzt dabei so ich bin ja auch sozusagen
dann auch ganz normal wieder nach hause
gegangen habe meine kinder ins bett
gebracht und darf dann abends auf dem
sofa und habe manchmal gedacht ich muss
mich einfach zwicken ich habe jetzt
gerade den papst heute getroffen ich
habe michelle obama mit michelle obama
tee getrunken das kann doch nicht sein
das war jetzt erst stand somit aber sie
macht man nicht mal so ganz oft auch
einfach heulend auf dem sofa wenn man
sagt dass es also ich meine kinder ins
bett bringen den ganzen tag lächeln
händeschütteln permanent seinen perfekt
oder monster alles meinen keinen blick
auslassen der also unter beobachtung
steht ich meine da sitzt man noch abends
da und sagt also es ist ist es eher so
dass man dass es schön ist wenn man
überhaupt mal auf dem sofa sitzt als
erstes und das waren dann war ich
einfach mal beine hoch und sozusagen
obligatorische jogging hose anziehen
kann wenn man das auch sonst natürlich
weichert das war das ja auch nicht
gewohnt
ich war natürlich in niedersachsen an
der seite meines damaligen mann ist auch
viel mit unterwegs aber das war ja nicht
annähernd dieser öffentliche fokus die
in denen es dann hier in berlin gab
und dann ist das auf der anderen seite
auch so dass man oder dass ich häufig
auch gedacht habt ich liebe da einfach
zwei leben irgendwie nah und das eine
ist natürlich auch ist eine öffentliche
rolle und das bild was
was da manchmal von mir dann gezeichnet
wurde mit dem war ich selber auch nicht
immer glücklich ist
das ist einfach ganz schwierig der auf
der der versuch überhaupt es anderen
menschen recht machen zu wollen
er schreibt eigentlich aber das kann man
immer im nachhinein gut sagen jetzt bin
ich ein paar jahre älter habe viel
erlebt und bin auch durch mediale ross
coolen gegangen und deswegen kann ich
jetzt auch weiß ich dass jetzt auch war
ein großer moment hast du hast ja damals
nicht suchen weiß als die ex mann dass
christian wulff zurückgetreten ist wo
sie standen das daran kann ich mich
tatsächlich sehr sehr gut erinnern
oh ja das glaube ich also wenn ihr grün
können sie sich erinnern wie wir es ging
ihnen da vor heute rückblickend benannt
hätten sie das anders gemacht oder
hätten sie also aus heutiger sicht
betrachtet hätte ich sicherlich anders
gemacht weil ich weiß aber auch dass es
damals nicht anders ging
also das war sozusagen tatsächlich dass
der die der letzte moment nach einer
unbeschreiblichen zeitlang manche sagen
auch mediale hetzjagd oder einfach einer
zeit die extrem war unter einem extremen
druck und trotzdem ja auch immer zu
hause noch nie gesagt eben auch eine
familie zusammenhalten wollen und auch
freunde und so und jetzt habe ich das
ich kann das alles irgendwie nicht mehr
übereinander bekommen eine mischung aus
totaler überforderung und erleichterung
dass es vorbei ist und dann auch
letztlich auch ein gefühl von 4 300
fotografen und journalisten ihr da jetzt
wie eine wand vor und steht ihr bekommt
kein gefühl von mir zu sehen so und das
ging dann nicht mehr also gedacht sodass
gehört wirklich nur mir her
das bleibt bei mir und das wirkte nach
außen auf viele kalt ist kristallisiert
genauso hab ich habe gedacht dass das
bekommt ihr nicht auch noch von uns ihr
habt jetzt versucht uns sozusagen jetzt
räche zu bringen ihr habt es geschafft
das bekommt ihr nicht
und was hätten sie heute anders gemacht
wenn es der tag heute war ich hätte
wahrscheinlich wenn ich wenn ich da
jetzt mit mehr abstand oder mit einem
großem abstand an den tag zurückdenke
dann wäre es mir wahrscheinlich jetzt
möglich trotzdem auch noch natürlicher
so zu sein
mit der situation umzugehen ja was
machen sie heute nicht an sich nahm also
das ist ja nett ehrlich ich hätte
wahrscheinlich hätte mehr emotionen
zeigen können ich wäre jetzt sicherlich
nicht mit meinem damaligen mann am hals
gefallen weil alles so fürchterlich ist
aber sondern das einfach zu zeigen das
ist natürlich mich und uns extrem
mitgenommen hat das ist menschlich
einfach nicht mehr zu ertragen war auch
und ich glaube das hätte der ganzen
sache auch ganz gut getan und ich glaube
das würde sowieso mal ein bisschen
schwenker zu kriegen wir sowieso politik
ganz gut tun wenn und dafür wäre jetzt
eigentlich auch eine gute zeit wenn man
auch betrachten würde dass das eben
menschen sind und dass es um menschliche
reaktionen geht so das sind personen die
versuchen es so gut wie möglich zu
machen
aber es sind eben auch menschen und die
funktionieren nicht einfach er ist
natürlich aber die erwartung an
politiker auch eine andere und da muss
ich auch sagen dass natürlich die
politiker natürlich den druck haben zu
funktionieren das bringt das amt auch so
ein bisschen mit sich die menschlichkeit
fehlt mir auch oft in der politik finde
ich auch das würden auch aber natürlich
müssen wir schauen dass wir dort
menschen haben die sich korrekt
verhalten diesem druck standhalten
diesem strengen protokoll folgen können
und natürlich dass auch mit einer
gewissen menschlichkeit und und
sympathie wir haben ja wir sprechen ja
nachher nochmal politiker sei die
frauenquote noch ansprechen war er
schnell so ein kleiner drehte nicht
jetzt machen würde
hört sich einmal kurz besprachen dann
aber kurz mal folgendes macht kurze
frauen foto und dann machen wir die
schleife wieder zurück zu den politikern
ja eigentlich menschlich sein die
eigentlich wünsche das war nämlich über
zwei männer dazu gleich mehr erstmal
frauenquote sein weil wir auch darüber
sprachen andere frieden zu stellen und
mich stellt natürlich ganz unzufriedene
frau zu hören
sie sagt ich bin eigentlich nicht für
die frauenquote und deswegen wird es
mich sehr interessieren warum das so ist
weiß tragen hier nicht darum es gibt bei
mir nicht ums prinzip also prinzipien
halte ich was das angeht ganz falls es
geht um qualifikation um leistung und um
darum dass jemand auch wirklich auch
frauen wirklich gewillt sind und das
finde ich eigentlich viel klüger ob sie
sich in dieses system eigentlich genauso
hinein begeben wollen ich weiß gar nicht
genau was genau richtig ist sich in
aufsichtsrat einfach grundsätzlich eines
sag jetzt mal großen automobil so eine
typische
domina deswegen fällt es mir ein eines
eines automobilherstellers hinein
kotieren lassen zu wollen
wenn ich dann da in diesem system in
diesem männer dominierten system einfach
das abliefern soll was von den letztlich
von allen anderen mir da von mir
verlangt wird also das alleine glaube
ich ist es nicht wenn ich als frau sage
ich will das machen
ich will in diesem aufsichtsrat weil ich
deine eigene philosophie hinter habe wie
ich meine dass man so mit menschen
umgeht und dass man ein unternehmen
lenkt oder oder sagt mal mit
kontrollierend einwirken kann dann ist
das was anderes
per se weil 30 frauen im aufsichtsrat
sitzen müssen mich damit hinein
nominieren zu lassen das halte ich das
sage aber es gibt ja immer das gericht
es gibt keine frauen spitzen vorstände
hören es gibt ja keine frauen wo die
frauen selber sagen dann besorge ich dir
für das gute frauen ja und ich kenne
genug frauen die die sich das auch
vorstellen können aber wo ist auch im
prinzip ist leider das ist eine
benachteiligung gibt aufgrund der
tatsache dass meine frau ist also das
sozusagen keine frage dass sozusagen die
strukturelle benachteiligung eben dazu
führt dass wir diese geringe zahlen
haben in deutschlands aufsichtsräten das
ist ja wirklich beschämend ja und und
dann zu sagen dass man keine frauenquote
befürwortet ich weiß was sie meint es
geht um die leistung diese frauen wollen
ja nicht bevorzugt werden weil sie
frauen sind aber sie wollen eben auch
nicht benachteiligt sehr gern und da
gehören auch das schon auch strukturelle
herausforderung dass man das auch so zu
sagen das wäre ja schade da hat
natürlich gerne den dinge die die
wirtschaft beziehungsweise der welt wo
man sagt wir brauchen keine frauen knot
und quote weil wir schaffen es auch so
aber leider ist es tatsächlich noch
nicht so optimal weitere mäßige frau
mittelmäßige max
[Musik]